- In the last weeks, and months,
we interviewed candidates
for different roles in our company.
And it was just insane to see and observe
what some of these people do
and say in these interviews.
In this video I'm covering
four tips for crucial mistakes
which I have observed other
people to do quite frequently
in these kind of job interviews,
and I'd like to discuss
them to help you avoid
these mistakes when you are
interviewing for new roles.
Hi guys, my name is Heinrich,
welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning.
I hope you're having all a great day.
Today I was sitting, again and still,
at my home office here in Munich,
and while I was working
on different tasks,
I was reflecting a bit on
the last weeks and months.
Because in our company,
and as some of you know,
I left consulting,
about a half a year ago,
and now I joined a retail
company in Germany,
and I have a CTO role in this company.
So in our company, in the
last weeks and months,
we interviewed different
candidates for several roles,
and now reflecting on that,
it was just crazy, right?!
So, while we had some amazing candidates,
that really fit the roles well,
we had also some candidates
which did or said things
which I just cannot believe
that these people said that.
So reflected a bit on that,
and I tried to come up with a
bit of a condensate of that,
so what were the top four mistakes
that these people were
doing in the interview.
And apparently, these
people didn't realize
that these were things which probably
didn't come across very well,
because otherwise they
wouldn't have done it.
And I want to help you
to avoid these mistakes,
that you do not do these mistakes.
If this is the first time that
you're watching my channel,
just let me briefly
introduce myself to you.
My name is Heinrich, and on this channel
I try to help you be successful
in the first years of your career.
So it doesn't matter if you're
a fresh college graduate,
or you're already in the
first years of your career,
this channel is all about tips and tricks,
what you can do to help
you become a professional,
and develop yourself
both from the private,
but also from the work perspective.
So if you like any of the
content on this channel at all,
please press the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to my channel below
in order that you get all the new videos
that I will release.
And of course also please
hit the notification bell
to make sure you're not missing out.
So, four crucial mistakes
that I have observed
these job candidates do.
Let's start with the first one.
So, this is a lack of
commitment and investment
from the side of the candidate.
So what exactly do I mean by that?
What I mean is that if
you talk to the candidate,
if you interview them,
there are just some people where you know,
you just directly sense,
that you are just one of
many companies on his list,
that probably is interviewing
with three or four companies
at the same time, and in the end
he doesn't really, really
care where exactly he works.
There are no really hard reasons
why he would prefer your
company over the other.
And in the end, probably the only thing
that would matter to him
is either the salary,
or maybe some other benefits.
But he does not really
care for your company.
And this especially becomes
obvious when you realize
that he didn't do any
basic research at all
about your company.
The bare minimum that you need to prepare
if you interview for a
company is to at least have
some basic stats of the
company in your head.
So, what is roughly the revenue
that the company is making?
How many employees do they have?
In what geographies do they operate?
So this is the bare minimum of research
and commitment that you need to show
in order for us as interviewers,
to make it clear that
you really want the job.
And of course, this is especially easy
if you work for a publicly traded company,
because for these companies
there are annual reports
that you can just flip through
and you will easily get
all of these key stats.
But even if it's not a
publicly traded company,
there are many other sources
of information that you can use.
So of course, on the one end side,
you could just look for
the company website,
or infos on there,
but even if the company
doesn't have such a website,
or doesn't provide these
kinds of information on it,
in most countries there is some type
of commercial registers,
where you can just pull
these kind of information.
In Germany, there's the handelsregister,
you can just look into Bundesanzeiger DE,
it's a publicly available
internet site in Germany.
And then you just type in
the name of the company,
and the latest annual
reports that are filed
from this company will be available there.
So even if it's not a
publicly traded company,
but an entity, or an LLC,
or in Germany, a GmbH,
you will get these kind of
basic financial information
on the company.
And of course, this might give you also
important insights as a recruit.
From my perspective, it
would seem very important,
if you look into joining a company,
to understand what the financial situation
is in which the company is in.
Is it doing well?
Is it not doing well?
If it's not doing really
well, what are the reasons?
Why is it not doing well?
How does this might affect your position
that you want to start in?
So do this basic research,
and then show your interviewer
that you did this research,
to give both sides some kind of comfort.
Now, talking about some positive examples,
what can you actually do in order
to really show some commitment
and investment into the company?
So what one of the
candidates, for instance,
did that we interviewed
is he visited several
of our stores, and he also made an order
in our online shop, to get a
feel of what the experience is
when buying with us,
both online and offline.
And he was able to, in the interview,
give us quite a few
tangible feedback points,
on what his experience are,
and what he would potentially
recommend to improve.
And as he was also looking to
work in a sales related role,
of course, this made perfect sense.
And this showed us that
this guy is serious.
I mean, he already did some effort
to understand what he could improve.
He already showed us
that he has the stamina
to really go there, do some test orders,
or just go out, visit stores,
and this already put him far ahead
of some other applicants
who did not even research
the most basic information on our company.
So do some research, invest
prior to coming to the interview
in terms of money, or
time, to show the people
that you are serious, that
you really want the job,
and are willing to go an
extra mile to get there,
and to provide and add
value for the company.
A second very big, very big mistake,
a second very big red flag,
the big mistake that many candidates do
is to not show any empathy,
to not show any self-reflection
in these interviews.
So very frequently,
interviews will consist
of some kind of questions of
the type that they ask you
what the interviewer thought
may be a difficult problem
that you faced in your professional life,
a special challenge that you had
in your professional life before.
Just to get a feel of
what type of challenges
you were already confronted
with in the past.
And then also how you react
in these kinds of situations.
And I get the feeling
that some candidates think
they should avoid at all costs
showing any kind of
weakness, any kind of doubt,
when answering these kinds of questions.
But this often leads to an
answer that sounds like this,
with the candidate pretty much saying,
"That there were these
tough and serious issues
"that I was facing, and all
these other people around me,
"they were clueless, they had no idea.
"They were idiots."
right?
"But I am then the big hero,
"and I walked in and I solved everything,
"and I came up with this great solution."
And the reason why these
kind of answers do not work,
or are not good answers,
is because they do not
show that you have empathy.
They do not show that
you have self-reflection.
That you can put yourself into
the shoes of your colleagues,
of other partners, and understand
what they are thinking,
what they're emotions are.
Because the truth is,
especially when facing tough
and challenging problems,
it's not black and white.
Some other people might behave
very counterintuitive to you,
it might be very difficult
for you to understand
why they are behaving in a certain way.
But if you try to put
yourself in their shoes,
and try to understand
what they are feeling,
what they are thinking,
then this often enables you to understand
their perspective, and then
also jointly collaborate
on at solution to a certain problem.
And these kind of team
oriented problem-solving skills
are highly important in a lot
of modern work environments.
And the reason why this is so important,
is that today leaders
need to have empathy.
It is really difficult to build followers
in an organization,
to build a tribe of people
that really supports you,
if you do not have empathy.
If you are not able as a
leader to also help them,
encourage them, enable them,
and all of this requires
empathy and self-reflection.
And make sure that in
your answers to these kind
of challenge oriented, or
problem oriented questions,
you show that you have this empathy.
This is just so important.
A third big mistake that
many people are doing,
is bad-mouthing their old employer.
And I get it, it's okay, right?
There's often a reason
why you left your old job,
maybe you quit the position,
or maybe your employer quit you.
And often this can leave
you with some bad feelings.
And of course, if asked,
it's completely fine
to maybe also mention a few points
where you disliked your prior role,
and what motivated you now
to make the transition.
This is, of course, absolutely fine.
No problem about that.
But then we had some candidates,
and not only one, but several of them,
went just on, and on, and on,
just talking bad about
their prior situation,
how all of their colleagues,
all of these other people,
just didn't get it, making
it sound like they were
pretty much the only
intelligent person in the room.
Describing all kinds of problems
at their prior employer,
and how they were the
ones who realized it,
but apparently everybody else around them
did not realize it.
And this type of behavior
is bad for two reasons.
First, it just makes you look
like a very negative person.
If I'm looking for
colleagues to work with,
I do not want to have a colleague
who is just complaining about everybody
and everything all day long.
I want some positivity around me.
And of course it's okay to also
make some critical remarks,
but this always needs to be in a context,
and not just out of a habit
of complaining all the time.
So this is the first reason,
but the second reason comes back
to another video that I did,
it's called the video "Problem
Solver, Problem Talker".
And I will include it above me,
that you can check it out
if you haven't seen it yet,
but it describes how a person
can either be a problem
talker, or a problem solver.
And I do not want to go into
all the details right now,
but if you are a person
that just complains,
or makes it looks like
you've got it all right,
you understood it all,
but just all these other
people around you didn't,
this very much makes you
look like a problem talker.
And for reasons I explained
in this other video,
what companies need and
want are problem solvers.
Because the truth is, the
likelihood is pretty high,
that all the problems
that you are describing
about your old employer,
there's a high chance
that you would have had
some opportunity to do
something about them.
So if all these things were going wrong,
what was your contribution
in your old company
to fix it, to make it better?
And again, the truth is
usually much more complex
then you being the intelligent
star who understood it all,
and wanted to do your best,
but you just couldn't.
Show that you solved these problems,
and then tried your best
to really add value,
and make an impact, and don't
just explain all day long
about what other peoples are doing wrong.
And my last mistake is
regarding body language,
and perceived energy level.
It is just important to understand
that how you are perceived as a candidate
is of course driven on the
one hand side by what you say,
but also, on the other
side, how you say it.
What your body language
is when you say it.
And just let me try to imitate it.
There were job candidates who were
just making themselves small,
who were sitting like
this in their chairs,
and some of them said some
really intelligent things.
But if you just say it by talking
in a very monotonous voice,
by talking with a very quiet voice,
if you just make yourself small like this,
this is just not how
you are perceived well.
It might be all right what you say,
it might make total sense,
but you seem like a person who cannot
articulate yourself well,
who probably has a problem with being
perceived with some kind of authority
in front of other people.
Who would probably have a hard time
persuading other colleagues,
which is of course an
important business skill.
And also is then perceived
with a low energy level.
And of course, this always comes down
to personality as well,
there are some people just naturally have
a higher energy level than others,
and this is completely fine.
But what usually do
not want as an employer
to have somebody on an extreme,
who just sits there, makes themself small,
and just radiates a very low energy level.
What you actually want as an employer
is somebody who just walks
there with lots of energy,
somebody who looks like he can tackle
10 new problems every day,
and can just move mountains, right?
And of course now I'm exaggerating a bit,
but this is what you're
looking out for as an employer.
So at least try to make
your best impression
in the job interview.
And even if you are a bit of an introvert,
this is completely okay, of course,
so no problem with that,
but try to at least show some
personality in the interview.
Show that you have some energy in you,
that you can move things, that
you are a mover and shaker,
so that you'll help your
potential future employer
see this kind of energy in you,
and see this ability of yours
to really tackle things,
go in there, and also go
into a fight, if required.
So these were the four mistakes.
So let me just reiterate, and repeat.
So the first is, not showing any kind
of commitment and investment.
Not showing some kind of
research that you did.
What you need to do is show
that you researched the company,
that you know the details,
that you maybe went the extra mile.
Maybe called the hotline
in the B2B company,
looked into a sales demo
to understand the product.
Maybe did a test order
of whatever the product
is of your company.
Show that you did an investment,
that you really want to
work for the company,
and add some value for the company.
Second, especially for leadership roles,
show that you have empathy and
the ability to self reflect.
Portray yourself as a leader
who tries to make an effort
to understand what other
people think and feel.
Because if you cannot do
that you will struggle.
And this is something that many
employers will look out for.
Third, don't express too much negativity.
Don't go on and on
criticizing your old employer,
just talking how bad everything was,
and how other people just didn't get it.
Show some positivity.
People do not want to be surrounded
by negativity all day long,
so don't be perceived
as a negative person.
And last but not least, look
out for your body language
and your perceived energy level.
Show that you have the energy
to tackle difficult tasks,
and don't make yourself
smaller than you are.
And don't talk with a
quiet and monotonous voice,
because this usually will not help you.
What I can just tell you,
now having interviewed several candidates
in the last weeks and months,
if you will do all these things,
in your next job interview,
I can promise you that you
are a significant step ahead
of many, many other job
candidates out there.
So, I hope this makes sense to you.
Let me know what you
think in the comments,
what are your tips and
tricks for job interviews?
What were situations that
you were confronted with
in your past?
If you have a question
about a difficult situation
that you maybe had in the past,
and you would like to have
my perspective on that,
let me know in the comments
and I'll try to give you an answer.
And if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please press the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
to help other people
discover this video as well.
And please subscribe to my channel,
and also hit the notification bell,
to see more videos like that.
And as some of you already
know, I also have a course
on how to create PowerPoint presentations
like top consulting firms do,
check out the link into the
description to this course.
There are already over
10,000 students who take it.
In the link you will see lots of reviews,
so have a look for yourself,
whether this is something that
might be of interest to you.
Thank you very much for watching.
I will release at least
one video every week,
on Saturdays on this channel,
so stay tuned, thanks again for watching.
I'm Heinrich from Firm
Learning, and have a good.